okay you've made your prediction and now  let's find out what the answer is so  I'll press on the side with the X of  course from above we see the X but what  do you see from underneath the glass  let's cut to the reverse angle  you see the Oh so Jared was right and I  was wrong  now some people think that I can never  admit that I'm wrong but this is clearly  an example of a time where I can you  know you make a prediction and you do  the experiment you find out that's what  science is all about and so I think  we've all learned something here and  hopefully you have a little bit more  evidence about how the spinning tube  trick works I look forward to your  answers